tied to rome as well and seen that
lineup obviously no sga tonight
next man stepping up
as giddy tears down the rebound the last
time getty played michael with that
really rare double double when he had
the 10 rebounds 10 assists and there is
a three from the outside by wiggins
might have punched it away
and sometimes that's all it takes
jerome
catched out of three from the corner and
that is good
[Applause]
okc
on the run how quick was that shot from
ty jerome he's not going to blow by you
he's just going to hit you with a skill
set the prodigy out of slovenia giddy
off the deck his three and he shows the
range knocking it down
very selective when he decides to take a
three little jab step there to take
a little space well sterling brown
played him right
gotcha shut off the valve on the
baseline
and so opening possession here in the
third get each one-handed pass to a
cutting tie jerome he got right outside
the restricted area and there's another
nothing to show for
his third point of it night all one of
eight shooting how about trusting this
pass
as a ball
is basically a hot potato
adjustments
how about this another nice dog
he delivered 28 assists
and it's from eight down to six as giddy
put it on a platter for pokashevsky the
happy melody up top
man
there's another tasty dish
[Music]
maneuvering his way around on the nice
pass roby on the reverse beautiful
finish underneath
josh skinny's got his 10th assist of the
night talk about you know guys that are
coming in out of that you know health
and safety protocol this is nice
i hate to stop it what i'm saying
partner but that is what you want in a
set piece